[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
stop playing games with your personal
protection try the walther today
see what i did there with the stop
playing games
walter's happy about it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
speedy
[Music]
hmm
that's the sound of well i was going to
say monday but it's not monday it's
tuesday uh because yesterday mr landau
filled in for me uh i was on the i was
on the street talking with people about
roe v wade
about four or five hours you're taken to
the streets taking it to the streets
and no joke i got sick to my stomach i
was speaking with someone who smelled
exactly how he looked oh no
and it was it was so potent along with
the the uh the marijuana cigarette that
he was smoking and blowing in my face
and i started dry heaving like uh alex
jones at the bumpus mites
so
that's coming i think uh tomorrow we're
gonna be running that it's just talking
with people at roe v wade seeing what
they know on the streets unedited kind
of like it changed my mind only it's not
sitting down at a table there's no
debate just let people
run with it and see what they believe
spoiler alert most people don't really
know what the rovi weight thing is but
today we're going to be talking about a
lot specifically uh karl marx communism
because of rhonda santos in florida
honoring the deaths
of the hundreds of millions of people
who've died under communism and my
question to you before we move on is you
know how's your portfolio looking today
uh and uh
how's your crypto
how's your crypto doing i'm not
anti-crypto i'm not into crypto but i'll
talk about it we'll talk about obviously
there's been a big crypto crash it's
just i think it's a very volatile it's
really a volatile commodity and it's not
necessarily the safest hedge against
inflation as you're seeing right now and
i think sometimes people sell it as
something that it uh isn't necessarily
but we have a lot to get to before we
get to that
gerald a is not here it's gerald b in
studio
doing the lamprey impression
doing the lamprey again always good with
the lamprey f me eyes yes those lamp
that's what lampreys do
vampires don't have eyes dave do they
comment below am i wrong i might need to
be admonished maybe lampreys do have
eyes
i have no idea i know what a lamprey is
yes you do you're from michigan
you don't they were all over the great
lakes they came in through lake
champlain and then they used to pay
people five bucks to go kill lampreys
and then they stopped oh i remember that
they're like giant legion of the big
teeth yeah yeah yeah i remember those go
on to you yep yep terrifying me now me
and a few guys went to find a dead body
i got one stuck in madrold yep yep
that's what they do they target your
most your most vulnerable locales uh now
you know him you hear him you love him
and by the way we're on tour together
lotto crowder.com tour tulsa this
weekend is sold out but we have colorado
in june and there will be a big fall
tour coming up hitting all the major
cities we're going to be in your
backyard you better come out and pound
us dave landau how are you sir ahoy i'm
good
you went with the uh you went with the
uh uh the ponyboy you went with the uh
the socials and the uh uh the the hair
the slick is it slick greaser in the
social it's just to the side
what was it the socials in in uh the
outsiders what was the other group the
socials and what were the what were the
good group uh
i don't remember i just remember the
socials because i pronounced it socks
yeah i haven't seen it in many years
unbelievable it's a good move casting
when you think about it you've got tom
cruise before this was if it's francis
ford
yeah and if if you guys have not seen
the outsiders and this is i know i'm
going off there but this is important it
is a master class in casting before any
of them are famous you have tom cruise
you have emilio estevez you have ralph
macchio rob lowe rob berlow patrick
swayze diane lane
this is before any of them were famous
yeah that's insane
tom cruise has like two lines in it i
don't know who casts that film but they
should cast all films
from here on out okay before i move on
to anything else uh
no one is happier
uh about us uh seeing women treated with
a greater level of fairness in today's
society than us here
right dave that's right yes ahoy yes i
didn't know we were looking for that did
you say it yet i think ahoy again okay
yeah i'll say it again well i was saying
ahoy as a yes uh so here is a female fan
if you missed it uh rushing the cage at
a ufc event being treated equally
oh my god
oh my god
welcome to the thunderdome well i'm just
glad to see equality working yes no
exactly i mean not in the amber herd
johnny depth trial but uh no she hasn't
lost work yet even though it's not she
beat him
yes we know that it's did he beat her we
don't know did she meet him well yeah of
course she beat him she'll lose work
yeah or she'll quit work when every
director is like all right this is a
bedroom scene try not to crap on it yes
uh have you seen our casting cat who
crapped on the couch oh there it is
amber someone check on my potted fern
so
yeah harvey weinstein's grossed out
buyer yeah exactly that's a that's a
weird place to be yeah that's a very
bizarre place to be and i you know
i will say this this is going to sound
terrible i would have been way more
upset seeing that a few years ago
which one the woman being uh you know i
would have been pissed about it's not i
don't care yeah nowadays i did care but
you shouldn't run at this stage no i
sort of that's how i feel you know i
feel confident like i wish that i cared
yeah
i imagine this is how a sociopath feels
a little bit about everything yes i wish
that i had feelings for this person
but i don't
well the entitlement for everything is
just going a little bit too far now yes
and it's just nice to see that rules are
being enforced violently again yes
exactly is that the right way to say it
i think it's the only way to say it
the entitlement of watch no man's going
to hit me i don't know i don't think you
like the way this one ends up buttercup
i can do whatever i want all the time oh
yeah go ahead let's try it let's tell
someone's like hey maybe no no no let's
all support her in this let's be we're
supportive of our friend you do you yeah
go ahead
i like how he's still taping too the
camera doesn't even move for his friend
no no he's probably seen that before
yeah oh yeah
he's no stranger to seeing her hit no
and hey by the way really quickly before
we move on uh wall 30 is the official
firearm sponsor of lot of crowder
studios let me do this so it's not one
of those rust situations this is people
who wonder what i carry this is the
uh the walther patriot it it is very
this is expensive because it's custom
made but now the new pdp that you guys
can buy they put in the same uh uh slide
serrations the super train slide
durations and it now has this same exact
trigger which if you go back and watch
when i was uh shooting
uh blowing up the youtube sign uh
i am not a very good shooter with this
thing it's a tack driver so go to
waltherarms.com
shop online they'll send it to your
dealer all i ask you look is this just
try the wall through that's it try the
walter if you don't like it then don't
buy it but just try it i'm confident
you have a walter yes yeah i shoot it at
helicopters yeah yeah that's not
necessarily anti-aircraft qualified but
i don't really yes that's it but makes
you feel good no no he does he does he
does do it he really does so
i think that they're spaceships
and then people correct me so now in
other good news the uh stock market uh
of course is uh just absolutely
continuing to to to crumble
since yesterday yeah yeah small
portfolio the s p 500 hit a 52-week low
the nasdaq is down 4.3 the dow is down 2
crypto is experiencing a major crash now
before all of you libertarians get mad i
look look
i think i have some crypto in my
portfolio there's nothing wrong with i
think that's johnny boy bringing in some
coffee here today um i have no problem
with you investing in crypto my problem
is just like when people sell gold and
tell you that it's a sure thing and it's
a hedge against inflation it's something
that is incredibly volatile and i've
seen a lot of people get screwed because
they've taken money out of their
portfolio and just said i'm putting it
all on crypto because someone on the
dark web told them to so bitcoin fell by
12 that's down 55 percent
in the last six months yeah well bill
devane uh told me silver
so i think he's on to something yeah
well i don't know if you know this he 23
in meet himself and it just said yukon
cornelius oh really yes oh dear
you kind of screwed he bothered me gold
and later was like sure
[Applause]
but but yukon silver is a far less
valuable precious metal than gold
nothing but what are we gonna make into
figaro chains in 1999 yes
this is important
hugo boss t-shirt come on so um here's
the thing rhinestone jeans now democrats
are trying to repeat the point that
you've heard the stock market is not
it's not an indicator of the economy
they want you to have an us versus them
that's just for really rich how is that
true well it's no it's not oh thank you
it's what they say yeah cause that seems
that would seem like it would be
directed you responded in an earnest way
yes yes but assuming they were being
truthful ah they're not that's my that's
my problem that is your problem i got
you you and your humanity what am i
doing oh gosh you're in the wrong line
of work so robert reich tweeted uh can
we please stop using the stock market to
assess the well-being of the economy the
gains are not being shared um first of
all kind of weird considering that
everybody lost a ton of money yesterday
you're a prick also
42 percent
of household wealth comes directly or
indirectly uh from held stocks also when
people talk about unions and pensions a
lot of people just don't realize that
this absolutely does affect everybody
but let me kind of draw a line for some
people who don't know how it affects
everything that you do on your day to
day it's a good it's a good assessor
of the economy it's not the end-all
be-all under donald trump the stock
market was doing well and unemployment
was incredibly low and labor force
participation was great and wage growth
was unprecedented right all of those
things were happening in tandem there
can be a disconnect like you see with
the real estate market that's not what
hap what is happening right now the
stock market is down because everything
in your life
financially
you should always be grateful you know
as a christian you probably have
beautiful family whatever if you're in a
wheelchair and you know
look the point is there's something to
be grateful for but financially your
life sucks
relatively speaking so uh reich was a
name you could trust yeah i know
especially with the middle name third i
know
what's happening in this world monday's
uh financial stability report the
federal reserve said elevated and
persistent inflation coupled with a
sharp rise in interest rates are among
the greatest near-term risks to the u.s
economic system okay so that's the
federal reserve and i really don't like
them but
inflation is expected to uh stay at over
8
in april if you use the same indicators
we used under carter it could be as high
as 14 because we decided well we'll just
change some of the metrics that we use
uh inflation is all that what does that
mean it's outpacing wages by 2.7 percent
that's why it's a tax on you the middle
class
there's you kind of have to pick a link
when people talk about taxing the
wealthier more and they say republicans
don't want tax they don't want tax
breaks for the middle class that's
actually first off that's just factually
incorrect second look
if you are talking about taxing the rich
more printing more money more government
programs more government spending it
inevitably leads to more inflation and
if your wages are not outpacing
inflation that is a tax on you the
middle class it affects you more than
the wealthy
it's outpacing your wage by 2.5 that
means that your your salary is worth two
and a half percent less than it was
this time last year
that's not a mundane detail michael now
gasoline all-time high national average
4.37
oh boy good god uh and of course because
of the increased interest rates
unemployment is expected to go up that's
also something that we're looking at
here in the near future we have that
overlay from the wall street journal so
uh in no small part due to the crappy
economy we're we're the good news is
that democrats are on they're on track
to get blown out in november that's why
they want to make it a roe v wade sing
and lie to you and say that republicans
want to ban abortion and they want to
put their hands on your uterus or
something like that uh in a generic
ballot republicans are leading democrats
i've never seen anything like this you
guys can comment below i've never seen
this kind of a spread
this kind of a spread it's like bird
shot
republicans to democrats the economy 42
percent to 26
that's how much they lead
on inflation republicans just generic
republicans
to democrats 41
to 20
that's a lot
i would say so i don't know how many
ballot boxes you would have to stuff to
make up for that margin but
good luck i don't know a lot but i do
know a bar graph length yes and that is
scary i don't even know the x-axis or
y-axis no
nope but that looks that looks larger
than the others that's why i like it
when they do it with colors yeah that's
where i go oh okay i understand it now
democrats are losing yeah that was black
and white i'd be lost and this is
something too i think it's look
i will say this too uh you'll see this i
think tomorrow where i had some
conversations with people on on roe v
wade so roey wade they're trying to use
it as a distraction issue it is very
important it is very important if roe v
wade is overturned that's a big victory
okay but the left wants to use it not
only to gin up riots the left wants to
use it to intimidate you into silence
and the left wants to make a certain
percentage of the population believe
that if republicans win they're going to
take your rights away that's why they're
saying it it's not true so the one thing
that republicans need to do is just keep
doing conservatives need to keep doing
what they're doing with the economy
they're already winning on roe v wade i
can tell you this tomorrow i i had a
conversation with four black people
on on the street corner
four black people on the street corner
and they were actually smoking joints so
we started talking about that they were
like nah man it's delta eight we started
the conversation
i swear to you
they offered me a hit
we started the conversation yeah i'm
pro-choice because you know you should
you should be right for a woman to
choose and i suppose should there be
like any limitations like for example i
don't know let's say like once there's a
heartbeat and it was three black guys
and one black woman and she's oh no when
there's a heartbeat yeah you shouldn't
be able to so after a heartbeat they
said no no definitely not after a
heartbeat i said okay so so you support
roe v wade being overturned so texas can
say a heartbeat
is the line they said yeah yeah yeah
definitely after it took about
three and a half minutes it just
requires a little bit of education with
roe v wade to let people know and
actually just kicks it back to the
states and they invariably go oh okay
that's not a big deal it takes it off of
the table take that off of the table
have that conversation with your friends
and family eliminate that issue and then
you get back to the economy then you get
back to where we are in the
international stage and it's not even
close
yeah very few people even believe the
nine month thing when i've told them
that i'm like no i'm telling you it's
nine months like there's no way i'm like
please look it up well here's the crazy
thing democrats can't put a limitation
because half of their base believes in
that when we spoke with people yesterday
and you spoke with hardline democrats
and we brought out a fetal chart and
said look just tell me where the line is
they said i don't believe in any
limitations you're like the one crying
with a name right yeah exactly what
about sydney would you kill sydney
and the hard-line democrats and you'll
see them the feminists the people who
are really aggressive the guy who looks
exactly like he smelled you'll see this
tomorrow you'll see we have a few
installments they said no limitations at
all and they said they would be mad if
democrats agreed to any limitations so
that's 50 percent of the democrat voting
base think about that they try and say
the republican party is controlled by
the extremist wing because they believe
in no limitations on constitutional
carry is it more extreme to believe that
someone should have the right to carry a
handgun or to believe that you should be
able to have an abortion all the way up
until nine months and including birth
because that's half of the democratic
party it's why no democrat on the
national stage will
will firmly state where there should be
limitations on abortion because they
can't they are beholden to those
extremists remove the roe v weight issue
from the table just requires a little
bit of education
then we get back to the economy then we
get back to the border because everybody
agrees all right
let's get to this though the uh the uh
the protests that are taking place the
borderline riots
um and uh juncken over there didn't do
anything for this so yesterday
pro-abortion these goons you know thugs
thugs coons low lives
scumbags they marched to samuel alito's
house to harass the remember when they
were showing on cnn they were right out
in front of kavanaugh's house remember
we were live i said do they need to do
that they were drawing coat hangers in
the street
i was like do they need to be right
outside of kavanaugh's house that's cnn
going here's where he lives
so now these people march over to
alito's and um they've been harassing
him based on the leaked opinion which of
course doesn't bother left at all even
though it's a serious crime
of roe v wade here are the kind and
peaceful protesters
they're wearing masks
losers
[Applause]
oh
there's a textbook projection they're
the ones that love abortion i'm not even
i'm not i mean i don't even know that
i'm pro-life when it comes to nickelback
a leader should start selling back awful
bands like yeah well you like sugar ray
and they're like butterfly was a good
song
that's my song
will you leave my property for limp
biscuit tickets can we do that can you
roll and roll and rolling out of here is
this
i think you're at the wrong address i
believe you're looking for three doors
down yes i hate everything about you
[Laughter]
this is what a smash mouth concert
smells like this is just their theme is
they're going like nickelback yeah let's
pick something that we think everyone
will agree on uh nickelback you don't
like nickelback you know what let's take
the opposite stance yeah i like
nickelbacks i think nickelback gets a
bad rap yeah i'm gonna go back i'm gonna
say i'm gonna give nickelback another
chance now because of them yep you know
what honestly nickelback wasn't that but
the problem is it's just all their songs
started sounding the same
i i uh it's not my but as far as like
compared to bands of that time that
we're doing it they're not any worse
than three doors down or certainly not
creed i saw them perform at a lions
halftime show uh longest concert i've
ever watched i can imagine because
you're also at a lion's game well it's
what we call a lose-lose oh believe me
it was uh
it's a long day
would you like me to go back to the
lions not scoring a touchdown
if you thought your day was bad already
here's nickelback yeah
it was honestly it was terrible and i i
really wanted to give him a break
because so many people hated him i'm
like i'll listen to this
and then like about a minute in i'm like
oh this is why yeah yeah this is not uh
well good for them i mean they're wildly
successful for being terrible that's
what's interesting about terrible bands
yeah
like the eagles or dave matthews dave
matthews good thank you thank you
finally someone said it he's crap yeah
or offense i know a lot of women and
wouldn't like him and stuff but he's not
i don't know he's not good well
hopefully they get kicked off a cage now
i love when his uh rv was like leaking
feces or whatever yeah like polluting
everything
was i don't know his couture with
stained oh lord was that stain i don't
know stained puddle of mud papa roach
all that some anytime a girl would have
one of those i'd be like oh well i know
that i know that i never want to date
you oh lord
you see a papa roach bumper sticker
you're like let's just call it quits
yeah it's not only that you made a
mistake it's that you didn't go through
the effort of erasing your mistake no
i just remember hearing that song on mtv
is that your approach no that's my dave
matthews oh dave matthews okay with his
stupid sandals don't worry you're
wearing birkenstocks on stage i don't
care for you yeah you know what else
i'll say you too
youtube sucks
youtube absolutely sucks i've been
saying it for years when they they gave
it they installed it unbeknownst to us
and all of our anyone remember this i
know some of you are too young they
installed it on all of our iphones for
free and we overpaid a lot and i was
really self-con my dad came once i was
like what is this youtube my phone is
like what are you doing like it's just
hardcore pornography yeah what's on your
phone i'm just watching a a three-man
train yes nothing it's lemon party leave
what's on your phone my dad's like uh uh
snuff films
just
you just hear through it yeah yeah yes
stop stop
i couldn't believe it was on there i'm
like i didn't order this yeah i know and
then why would i listen to this so look
at those stupid glasses and that guy who
calls himself the edge who walks in and
calls himself the edge and everyone goes
with him yeah exactly i would have you
committed yes if i ever come in here and
i just have a new name that's like that
i'm the sword you're like dave uh where
are you going to the hospital yes
exactly
yeah how about a man in straightjacket
yeah that's a native american is one
coal
that's what we'll call you oneco which
means one in straight jacket
it's already bono
now you're i'm the edge i'm edge
all right
so look these are the these are the
protests that we're seeing outside of
the houses which we knew would happen
that's why the leak had taken place and
uh what's worse is of course these these
low lives they're they're being
empowered
by the white house
you guys have criticized leeds before as
it's been provided so matt you've
criticized in the past why not criticize
this league again because i think what
is happening here and what we think is
happening here is there is an effort to
distract from what the actual issue here
which is the fundamental rights
i don't think they're at the same level
we don't think they're at the same level
they're not the same level but would you
agree that it's still worthy of
condemnation well look i think there has
been a call for an investigation by
leaders of the supreme court decisions
on that and how it will be received will
be made by the department of justice and
others and that's certainly their space
and right to make that decision in
government that's how government is set
up but at the same time what we've also
seen peter is many republicans who are
trying to overturn a woman's fundamental
rights try to make this about the leak
this is not about the leak this is about
women's health care and women having
access to health care making choices
with their doctors now i had my
suspicions and i was wondering why they
were i didn't know exactly why
but we've confirmed why she is in fact
so protective of the leak this is right
up there this is right up their alley
yeah yes
figures yeah i had a feeling
have the leaks do your dirty work
ah i knew it i should be ashamed but i'm
not now for people listening on audio
what's going on trust me you're not
missing anything now you're fine it's
best you don't it's best you don't don't
don't watch the show
uh this is uh what to be fair that was
from a week ago
so i'm sure she strongly condemned the
leak since seeing the reaction the
violent protests right she must she's
condemned it strongly since then does
the president plan to condemn the leak
of the supreme court draft opinion or
the doxing of the justices now that
we've seen violence unfold the answer is
yes well i would say that we have been
clear and the president's position has
long been that we should not see protest
that takes the form of violence that
takes the form of vandalism um and
that's what you are saying threatens
anyone um that has long been his
position for his entire uh career and
continues to be his position oh okay so
she's still a turquoise piece of [ __ ]
and why is she wearing the same outfit
it's like camouflage you don't wear
turquoise on a turquoise background also
kamala harris said they should keep
riding they should continue so again
you've set there's a precedence and a
precedent we can use both we can apply
them here of you guys encouraging
rioting and now we're seeing it happen
as the direct result from your lies
they've asked you to condemn it twice
and you haven't you say well i think i
can point to the record that's the
problem is your record yes well if she
wants to avoid answering questions she
should take a little advice from this
guy in hong kong
how about reconciliation with those who
were not satisfied with the government
thank you
well i think the echo here really makes
it not easy to hear exactly but
my
election
and also can you elaborate on your
kovitzero plan
i i i will have to request you to repeat
this the echo
mixes up a lot of things
well i too have a problem with my amazon
echo yeah me too he keeps listening to
me beat my wife yes
what's role-playing i think you're off
the cage joke yeah my wife could hurt me
yeah
the echo cancel i will enter something
else
hero
yes the echo means uh so let me read uh
this uh the echo i think you asked why i
am best candidate by best politician
ever thank you yes next question i can't
hear because of the echo did she say
covert zero yes i did that um yes yes i
don't know because of the echo
[Laughter]
i didn't even know you could just do
that you just don't answer the i mean
kamal harris did that we just don't
answer the question i wish i could just
do that in life just i'm just not gonna
it's like just pretend you're hard of
hearing and nobody can help you right
you're saying i don't know i wish
somebody could speak into my ear i got
nothing yeah sorry yeah or just answer
something completely different like yeah
how old are you yeah tuesday yes it's
true i did get straight a's in my
humanities thank you very much yeah i
donate a lot so she's not uh condemning
it but it's it's really funny again
because this is now
but considering how vehemently how
passionately democrats condemned uh
leaks historically
let's be clear
this disclosure
is not just an attack on america's
foreign policy interests
it is an attack on the international
community
the alliances and partnerships the
conversations and negotiations
that safeguard global security and
advance economic prosperity let's be
clear oh crap
why don't they say let's be clear do you
realize it's always something that's
very unclear
yeah
it's not just me no it's very unclear
okay yeah so saki's not condemning it
okay fine
but i will say you have to take the ones
where you can't at least democrat
they're not
insinuating anything or calling anyone
to anything too radical like telling
people to take up you know arms is that
sarcasm stephen you're silly billy why
would that be
why would that be sarcasm is it
oh i see oh good catch dave look at that
you saved me yes because i was i was
giving them the benefit of the doubt
that's right
that's exactly what uh chicago mayor uh
and uh beetlejuice stand-in told people
to do uh uh
to my friends in the lgbtq plus
community this looks like something that
jeremy wade would pull out of river
monsters
to my friends in the lgbtq plus
community the supreme court is coming
for us next this moment has to be a call
to arms now i know she probably meant
figuratively but that's the benefit of
the doubt that's not given to you know
for example donald trump the sitting
president who was removed from all
social media platforms
yeah if you say her name three times in
a road will she go away
is that the problem i i think if you say
her name three times in a row she shows
up in the mississippi river
yeah she migrates i see okay get that
carp eye
you got enough money get it fixed just
use some of that insider trading dough
to just fix the google
i don't know
so here's what else we've got glenn
glenn young and the governor of virginia
where alita lives dropped the ball by uh
he didn't for the mob what he did was um
nothing
the most he can muster was this
half-assed tweet it says we have been
coordinating with fairfax county pd and
federal authorities to ensure that there
isn't violence virginia state police
were closely monitoring fully
coordinated with fairfax county virginia
police will assist federal and local law
enforcement blah blah blah blah blah
blah no one's been arrested
no one's been arrested thus far there
have been no consequences at all this is
the problem this is where we are people
need to face consequences like that lady
at the ufc event with the cage guess
what she probably won't do that again
oh if she'd had a gun knife she wouldn't
have had any charges pressed again no
she wouldn't have so you actually should
have done it more accurately that's just
black on black good old tom four yeah
that's fine totally acceptable how about
we just arrest people like around
elito's house he has the authority to do
that
he has the authority to do that you know
what else you can arrest people for
misdemeanors you can arrest people for
disturbing the peace you can arrest
people for vandalism you can arrest
people for trespassing there are plenty
of ways that people can be arrested and
this can be stopped and not to mention
people in the neighborhood can be made
to be safer also do you know kavanaugh
his neighbor is part of the protest
she's the one who's been helping to
organize a protest you're serious yeah
oh i'd egg her house yeah i'm gonna say
it yep i'd at least cover it yep toilet
paper
kavanagh you wouldn't kevin you need to
you need to light some [ __ ] on fire yeah
exactly exactly do it come on gotta do
it we know there's some bourbon in your
house just stick a rope in i am being
100 serious cavanaugh yes we know that
you're above it yeah but don't we don't
be above it yeah okay joke just wear a
mask spray paint the ring doorbell from
the side oh i forgot to mention we have
donald trump jr on the show too oh okay
that's not it's not a it's a we really
do have donald trump jr on the show
today okay i just yeah i forgot to tell
people there you go so uh i completely
forgot to let people know kind of a big
deal so let's contrast junkin uh who's a
puffy boy with
ron desantis uh who just announced
november 7th
as victims of communism day this is one
day
i am signing hb 395 which will
officially designate november 7th as
victims of communism day to honor the
more than 100 million people who have
fallen victim to communist regimes
[Music]
now here's the thing people will say why
is he doing this this is political
grandstanding for the same reason i'm
about to read you some letters from karl
marx here which trigger warning you're
not going to like what karl marx
believed it's that you need to draw
attention to the fact that communism has
killed hundreds of millions of people
and the next dumbass who tells you that
religion is the cause of all wars just
tally up the communism death count which
is a distinctly atheist and racist idea
religion is not the cause of all wars
people wanting other people's crap is
the cause of all wars whether it's
native american tribes who are warring
whether it's
you can go back to
the roman empire greeks you can go to
the ottomans people have fought for
christians more there were more
christians who were killed by other
christians than the wars between often
between muslims and christians people
don't realize this people of the same
religion killed each other over reasons
related to land and resources and with
communism you're looking at hundreds of
millions of people killed okay
attention needs to be drawn to that
because for some reason your professors
and the kids who always have their hand
up in your class and talk about the
capitalist system man like helen keller
did you know that did you know this that
helen keller is complete and total
[ __ ] did you know that did you know
that helen keller is complete and total
[ __ ] right now you can google helen
keller socialism and read socialist
screens from helen keller that just so
happened to be the exact verbatim
type of manifestos that her handler anne
sullivan had written a long time before
he was going like
she's like oh she's saying that uh this
is the plight of the of the proletariat
and we must take over the bourgeoisie
oh yes i agree as well we need to
endorse the national communist candidate
it's bull crap like what would you buy
if you were even helen keller you
wouldn't care about money i mean what
could you do with it yeah i mean you
could feel it maybe you can feel that
and some grass yeah water
scream she knows the difference but this
is something that we've been talking
about for a long time and i do recommend
you go and watch uh jordan peterson's
two-hour
takedown of communism here's a clip go
watch it something was rotten in the
state of denmark malcolm muggeridge went
over to the soviet union to check out
how the collectivization of the farms
was going and he found out it was
actually pretty murderous
right because what this what the
communists did was round up all the
successful farmers and rape them and
kill them and steal everything they had
and send them off to siberia which
turned out actually to be a pretty bad
idea
literally says things that are just
horrible and he's like turned out to
actually be a pretty bad idea that's
what i love about his voice there you
know when you think take into account
the running over people with tanks and
the hundreds of millions of people who
are executed all the facets that make up
the variables not cool man yeah not good
things
i was i was snorting benzos
no he really that look i'm going to say
he he did he his wife was dying of
cancer and the guy i totally understand
i'm saying it as an addict as a joke
yeah i'm not making fun of him no i know
i listen to you you've been giving so
much [ __ ] for that and it's like well
it's ridiculous that's why i'm joking no
i know i like jordan relax everybody and
i'm just saying it's i'm saying it so
that you don't get the crap in the
comments section
dave likes jordan peterson i'm an addict
making an addict joke
doctors told him to take this is the
problem that you run into
kind of like the vaccines we'll get into
the pfizer papers one of these days just
because a doctor tells you to take it
guess what you can find another doctor
who says you shouldn't take that
it was a bad idea well it's relatively
new that they thought that we could get
into it forever they just wanted to give
them crap about something and they found
another thing to give them crap about it
right matter they were going to find
anything they were pissed off at them
they wanted to cancel them so they found
addiction isn't that a nice shitty thing
to hold somebody down isn't it the left
who also talks about whenever a school
shooting stuff when we sometimes talk
about mental health but then it's used
against people also sort of like johnny
depp right now in the trial right yeah
wonder why men don't want to get help
for their mental health right when you
constantly weaponize it
oh man you should you shouldn't be angry
you should you should just you should
cry you should be vulnerable every time
men in society reveal their underbelly
in the hopes that you employ the mercy
rule
you decide to strike a finishing blow
that's why
it's not our fault
it's yours well it's almost like you
can't do anything right and they're just
looking for something for you to be
wrong about every turn almost almost and
by almost i mean that's exactly every
time yeah i have absolutely every time
and by the way let me talk about karl
marx a little bit because a lot of
people since they're bringing awareness
to communism i think we should get to
the founder of the feast karl marx now
i've discussed karl marx's writings that
you probably had to read in college
where someone says it's beautiful in
theory it's not but uh today i want to
get into his his personal views that you
didn't find in some of the official
papers or the books that had been
written which were also
far more offensive and i want to uh sort
of juxtapose that with the uh the idea
that we're canceling historical figures
whether it's jefferson whether it's
washington now it's abraham lincoln so
before we get to that i would recommend
you go and watch a few years ago i did a
20 20 something minute video
specifically on karl marx life under
communism here's a quick clip in a true
free enterprise system that corruption
is mitigated by the concept of
competition now invariably when that
corruption does occur repeatedly and
systematically as you see with big banks
big energy big unions that can only do
so when abetted by big government big
banks are able to continually be corrupt
why not because of capitalism but
because of a never-ending supply of big
bailout funds from equally corrupt
politicians now at least you can still
choose to use a local bank or credit
union who never required bailouts to
begin with but let's change the scenario
the big corrupt government you and i
both hate for bailing out big banks now
it is the bank it is your only bank it
is also your only grocery store your
only phone provider your only health
insurance that's communism as seen with
every communist regime ever it leads to
massive death and totalitarianism every
time
okay
so we know about the results right the
ripple effect of
marx and then and then people say well
marx and there's lenin and i'm a marxist
but i'm not a leninist
whatever i don't care anywhere communism
has been tried it just
exclusively death follows and that's the
difference when people say well some
people have died under the capitalist
system and they try and tally up
everyone who's died from obesity heart
disease starvation whatever over the
course of time as opposed to the direct
result of communist policies leading to
the death of people if not just
including the actual death marches that
had taken place so it's not a valid
comparison it doesn't pass the sniff
test but let's also point to here the
hypocrisy not just the effect of
communism
of canceling historical figures here in
the united states let me ask you this is
a con this is i'd love to see a comment
have any of you seen
on your college campus
uh or anywhere in your community the
demand that any type of karl marx
whether it be his books in some places
they have statues they have a little
head you know on the desk that's how you
know you're important when it's a bronze
head i don't know why people do that
have
there been any examples of people trying
to get those pulled
like the left with to kill a mockingbird
or huck finn
i i'm not saying it hasn't happened i
haven't seen it which surprises me
considering just how racist and by
racist i mean
he believed in racial superiority karl
marx actually was actually communism the
way he saw it didn't work without the
elimination of certain undesirable races
including the jews and the blacks to
which he referred to with far more
colorful language which we'll get to in
a second so well things like to kill a
mockingbird another side that's been
taken down statues of lincoln these were
pro these were things that were progress
right or the end of racism right that's
what i find so amazing by trying to get
rid of those things right so we want to
erase the good part right the part where
there's a transition period would you
think that abraham lincoln was going to
be saying four score and men can lack
men can uh get pregnant too yes no he
wasn't gonna do that he was just like ah
you know we shouldn't have slaves those
are those the first steps
whereas
karl marx was extremely racist indeed
he wasn't a man of his time he was a man
in his time where people were like oh
marx he really shouldn't hate the jews
in black so much
[Laughter]
laying it on a little thick
so
here's his essay from 1843 titled the
jewish question karl marx
what is the worldly religion of the jew
huckstering
what is his wordly god
money
well that's
that one seems pretty self-explanatory
anti-semitic yeah kind of anti-semitic
uh also by the way it's sort of funny
because he was born to two jewish
parents
oh that's jewish parents so i wonder if
this whole thing was just
payback against his mom oh boppy why did
you keep throwing your mats under oh
shut up mother
you say i never about anything i'll
start the genocide then you'll see what
are these symbols you've been drawing
all over the house oh you'll find out
soon enough
did you pee pee in the fridge
yes i did what's it to you it's a mess
there's no fridges in this time i'm a
big communist now
did you did you [ __ ] on my bed oh there
was you ever heard yes yes she has a
delorean oh she's oh what is the worldly
religion of the jew huck's ring now
let's read marx's letters to angles so
here's the thing
it's not just that it's not just an
anti-semitic comment it's him saying
jews are dishonest stop using jamaica is
a coaster
but what else will i use it for to
humble myself before god i don't believe
in him stop trying to make me you i'm
not you
[Laughter]
i am going to write an entire i am going
to create an entire
ism
that will be based around the fact that
you need to be extinguished how about
that how about that then we'll hear you
[ __ ] about the monarch the the yamaka
as a coaster it will seem like small
ladkas at that point
did you sharomize your brother with the
menorah
i'm going to please the fifth even
though i don't know what that is because
i'm here in
i'm not in the united states
yes yes i did i did do that so here's
marx's letter to angles if people
haven't read this
it is a misfortune that magnificent
california was seized from the lazy
mexicans
wow who did not know what to do with it
so we've hit the jews we've hit the
mexicans karl marx again i'm just
wondering is this enough is this enough
to pull his books is this enough to pull
any of his beautiful in theory because i
don't hear people saying oh abraham
lincoln or george washington thomas
jefferson was beautiful in theory where
they wanted to free their slaves upon
their death and they believe you know
but you know they took some a while to
get there no they just removed the
statues they called them racists they
called them white supremacists
but they say it still it's really
beautiful in theory what karl marx
believed in well let's see what he
believed in in addition to the writing
which created difficult effect and led
to hundreds of millions of people i've
also never met a lazy mexican
that's a good point
just sort of a racist pointless thing to
say yeah exactly i mean there's certain
stereotypes you can't say it's like
listen they're lazy but they also do
jobs that germans don't want to do yes
and they do them for very little money
and very well invest yes yes honestly uh
but they are lazy because i need to
label them with something because i have
the juicer tricky i'll get to the blacks
here in a second in my 1862 letter to
engels so it's sort of really more of a
bridge i just said mexicans are lazy
that's what's lazy on my part is it me
maybe it's me my cleaning lady is
honduran and i get i have i have mexican
friends but you know i'm a racist that's
what i have to do don't wave at her
she's not a person
so this is from his 1862 letter to
angles
it is now absolutely clear to me that as
both the shape of his head and his hair
texture shows he descends from the
negros who joined moses's flight from
egypt unless his mother or grandmother
on the paternal side hybridized visa and
i'm going to not whitewash this
hybridized v [ __ ]
now this combination of germanness and
jewishness this a primarily negro
substance necessarily creates a strange
product
and then he sticks the lendings the
pushiness of the fellow is also
word like
wow that is uh
so he's using it in its context to say
god forbid we mix because
n words are inferior is what karl marx
is saying there it's not that he just
said it out of context he wasn't singing
along to kanye's dropout if you read his
writing he firmly believed that black
people were superior were inferior to
white people you know who else believed
that pretty much all communists that's
why we have the cheverus shirt mocking
him do you know what he said about black
people
this is the thing that people sort of
they try and say far right-wing nazis
for our left-wing communists no it's
actually really very similar because for
communism to work
they believe that you had to have a
society of people who would work and so
it was very puritanical as far as race
and so is we need to eliminate this race
we need to eliminate these hucksters we
need to eliminate these liars it was the
same thing with the nazis when people
said nazis weren't socialists they were
really far right-wing no no they
believed in socialized healthcare they
believed in national socialism they just
believed it could only work
if you got rid of the people who weren't
part of the aryan race guess what it's
still the case today if you look at
actual neo-nazi groups and they're very
very few and far between just about what
the media tells you they believe in
socialized health care they believe in
all sorts of social safety nets and
welfare benefits they just believe that
it would only work if you got rid of
mexicans and blacks
it's always been this communism from its
very start necessitated a racist
point of view
i can't believe i'm communist
jewish parents that must have been an
awkward thanksgiving well he wouldn't do
thanksgiving nobody on that it's a joke
everybody got quiet like i was serious
so if you're wondering what to get your
strange friends on the left this
november 7th uh considering uh giving
them a copy of karl marx racist
i'm going to give that to everybody just
because of the cover yeah exactly okay
what is this i don't know just for you
and ignore that there are one star
reviews on there but that's just because
the left is trying to cope well of
course they're like you're taking it he
was a man of his time uh there were men
of his time weren't that big of a piece
of [ __ ] well that's fine he's a man of
his time but you're using the man of his
time to justify how you behave in our
time yes that's the problem exactly this
is the issue is is if you go back again
to the founder of the feast like we talk
about with islam
are there plenty of of great
moderate muslims of course there are no
yes yes but muhammad was not one of them
oh dear muhammad was not one of them
muhammad killed muhammad beat his wife
muhammad had a six-year-old wife he may
have only consummated when she was nine
that's best case scenario muhammad
called for the deaths of christians and
jews so you wouldn't say muhammad would
be one of the moderate muslims that you
praised today i think you would say
i think you would say that about jesus
christ
what's the worst thing you could say
you'd be like it's kind of weird
a little a little bit like he doesn't do
anything wrong did jesus ever hurt
anybody no did you just ever call for
the death of anybody no did you just
ever beat anyone no
did you just ever hit a woman no
he actually seemed like he was probably
pretty fun in other words if you were to
say okay i bet he'd hit kathy griffin no
yeah i think that's all of us jesus
would be like look this is this is the
only time you would ever hear jesus go
jesus christ and be like can we add a
commandment to it yeah no but seriously
this is the founder of the feast you
have karl marx who do you go to okay
question who do we go to for communism
where we don't find a piece of [ __ ]
because i know i know and you can't hide
we can't give people a quarter where
they go oh they didn't do communism
right
who would do it right
socialism who would do it right don't
even try and go to the scandinavian
countries because even the danish prime
minister said stop saying it we're not
socialists we created all of our wealth
in a free market economy we're a blended
economy who has done it right let's okay
russia no china
no north korea no
where where do you want cuba no
and if you you have to go and visit
there and prove how great it is yes like
that's the deal and this is also great
for your trip if you make it alive well
this is also how you see the media is
full of crap because michael moore did
that film sick i thought well no one's
going to take the serious seriously i
mean he's saying that cuban healthcare
is better than american healthcare
but then they rated
socialist systems of healthcare where
people die at an exponential rate
when compared to the american healthcare
system as higher than ours why because
it's a self-rating system of people
saying yeah i think my healthcare is
pretty good that's because they don't
know anything else is there an example
that doesn't suck with communism or
socialism and this is why it's important
for people like just like i said educate
people on roe v wade
ron desantis is doing this to make sure
that people are aware because guess what
there's how do you counter balance when
people say how do you cut our balance
what's going on in college
all these institutions that have been
infiltrated well you know
without
what
to college but starting with a day to
recognize the hundreds of millions of
deaths from communism that's a good
place to start yeah that is
also in the movie sicko michael moore uh
never gets like a physical or shows his
doctor reports no i think that would
have been really great to see yeah it
would like you know your cholesterol is
death yes yes
your blood type is pudding yeah this is
uh this isn't we actually weren't even
able to draw it through the syringe
because it was so viscous you've been in
this room four minutes and i don't think
we'll ever get the smell out no i don't
think and also the town of traverse city
when you go and do your film festival
have you been there for the michael
moore when they do the oh no he doesn't
include michigan residents no that's
right
it's a
scumbag everyone in michigan we're
michiganders we know michael moore and
no one there you can to the rest of the
country you can keep him oh you smell
like an inner city planet fitness
sounds like a locker room at a golf club
yes
smells like the inside of a fake leg is
this a hockey rink or is it
oh my god please i do not want to see
michael moore in a hockey rink when we
know what cold temperatures do to the
human body oh remember him on ice
capades oh
michael more escapades what him just
laying there like a whale yeah it's just
on the frozen water bowling for
columbine on ice
there's people coming out with nine
millimeter carbines and michael moore
skating doing a
quarter axle yeah
before his leg just snaps from weight
looks like that scene in fantasia just
a hippopotami he doesn't even have
skates he just has two sleds
two illusions
they're taped to his feet like moon
boots yeah
all right
when do we have a don jr coming on
uh we're supposed to have him in 10
minutes all right see if he can come
earlier but i got it we have some chats
too okay well bring us some of the guys
in there bring us something from
breaking news because i don't we don't
often have guests so right now we're
just we hit everything i needed to say
about communism let me know if there's
something happening right now in the
news cnn is talking about uh finland and
sweden sweden being on the verge of
joining nato sveden isn't that hilarious
sweden joining nato wasn't their big
claim to fame that you know they only
had two claims to fame that they loved
remaining neutral and and fish
yeah that was it oh is that i think
birth control too didn't first control
come from sweden
i don't know
maybe maybe eugenics sweden might join
nato because now they're like oh wow
this can affect us yeah
with all the rest of you and we were
inconsequential we were neutral but now
we're concerned about ourselves we need
to join nato it's like oh okay how about
this you get to join nato when you make
all the back payments this is one of
those things with nato and people said
you really think we should pull out a
nato nato is a screw job it's the united
states funding the security for the rest
of the world look when people from and i
was raised in canada and it's a shitty
place with a shitty prime minister and i
wish it was not a shitty place when they
brag about their social safety net and
their free health care and insert
whatever other free crap there okay
let's change one variable pay for your
own national security go okay europe
when you [ __ ] about the united states
and how were this world superpower or
evil blah blah blah blah blah blah yeah
how about you just back pay internet
just pay what you're supposed to pay in
the neighbor what is it two percent of
your gdp a lot of you did about
0.5 the united states was paying 4
why should we be footing the bill for
the rest of the world security i'm not
against war when appropriate
certainly not to defend europe because
they weren't willing to spend money to
defend themselves and canada would not
exist if not for the united states
military i get so sick sweden joining
nato
how how long have we had to hear about
hear them virtue signal about being
neutral until they finally maybe have
some skin in the game well and how much
help is that gonna be i know what are
you guys gonna bring a few chefs yeah
some cheese
they do cheese in sweden i don't know i
don't know
we have fish if swedish fish all i know
about that is there was a liquor store
where you would buy uh swedish fish by
my house when you were a kid i was
pretty dirty yeah it was very in there
you buy like five and the guy's like
that was no quarter yeah it's very tacky
yeah it's no good you can eat this or
you can put it under couch so it's not
slide on hardwood yes what do you want
here i said full purpose i handle money
all day and here how many you want yes
we don't have money for scoop
my hand is scoop
would you boys not stop looking at the
pornography tapes that i have placed
clearly in your review yes maybe i think
i should not place them next to skittles
but it's too late now is liquor store is
toy guns pornography and swedish fish
what are they talking about here and
said biden backs unlinking ukraine aid
and coveted funding hey how about this
how about this
how about no aid
that's not obama it's racist and how
about no covet funding
how about that i know that's good that
makes me a right-wing extremist at a
certain point do you guys realize how
much money we're spending haven't we
paid enough for covid you would just you
know livelihoods and freedom and yeah
isn't it enough and trillions of dollars
yeah isn't that enough you know what i
was just watching yes uh two days ago
the film contest the shower what the
film contact oh yeah i remember that i
can move with mcconaughey matthew
mcconaughey jody foster it's actually
not a bad film uh it's one of the few
films where the third act is a lot
better than the first two acts yes but
they were talking slow burn yeah i like
a slow burn it was i liked it i liked
the film and they were talking about you
know the building this thing that will
send her out to space to
contact planet vega and i think they
were saying if if completed this would
be a 300 billion dollar the most
expensive infrastructure project ever
and i'm sitting like
what was our which i know we had one
bill that was 2.6 trillion but how much
did we spend in all the infrastructure
bills now i don't know what it adds up
to it's definitely over six trillion
yeah they're sitting there can you
believe 300 billion dollars and all
sitting there before a committee you're
like this is too much money
they're like please
how much do you want us to print yes and
we don't even have any this is all
pretend where are we gonna get 300
billion dollars it doesn't even exist
hey we just got this new thing called
crypto yeah you want some of that that's
a bunch of it yeah i got bitcoin and
then nothing i was like i'm an ethereum
guy
oh why are you how does that work it's
all i don't know fairy dust it's not
real so this is it just shows you how
far we've come 300 billion dollars do
you realize how much we're spending i
just had someone this will come up
tomorrow again the guy who smelled
exactly like he looked saying we haven't
spent uh you know for example the united
states we don't spend anything on uh on
uh helping people who are poor and i
said we've spent hold on a second we've
spent trillions of dollars on the war on
poverty absolute [ __ ] and he goes
yeah well look around they're still poor
people and i said okay okay okay well
that doesn't mean you cure it
so can then can we agree can we agree
then that the government clearly isn't
spending the money correctly because if
you believe that elon musk can solve
world hunger with 40 billion you should
certainly be able to solve american
poverty with a few trillion dollars if
throwing money at it worked it doesn't
work michael you can't just throw more
money at a problem public schools suck
have they gotten better no have you
increased spending yeah what's the
solution spend more money
why are there still poor people oh
you're right i that's a good point if we
didn't we didn't make everyone rich yeah
sorry about that sorry speaking of our
leaders misusing money we mentioned
laurie lightfoot earlier in the show and
her we're called to arms uh beetlejuice
oh yes sorry beethoven juice and her
called arms for the supreme court that's
strike one three strikes three strikes
if you don't refer to her as is
mayor beatles just trying to just don't
say it three times yeah don't say three
times yeah so beetlejuice is going to
make chicago an oasis for abortions and
she's spending her money where her mouth
is five hundred thousand dollars for
abortion access in chicago an oasis for
a wait
like this is it is such uh
it's just this nonsense thing to throw
everybody into an argument to keep us
all blind the same as covid was for how
many years it's all and i know that
people are very passionate about it but
it's just [ __ ] are we back to
dealing with bands did you she meant
oasis is gonna come out maybe
i'm gonna kill you my baby
and after all
i'm gonna keep you in your balls
[Laughter]
today was gonna be the day that i'm
gonna suck you down a tube
[Laughter]
you know it's gonna tickle and you feel
like you have to poop
just always well good chicago you know
what they needed a refreshing they
needed a little bit of a facelift in
chicago they did making her the city of
abortion yes that's great
yeah
are you just gonna do it with guns like
what do you do just
you just set a woman by a window and
wait for a bullet my gosh chicago okay
we have our uh all right we have our
guest here on the line uh i'm looking
forward to speaking with him everybody
uh let's get ready we're staying here uh
donald trump jr
[Music]
all right mr i can't see him there uh uh
tool man uh mr
trump jr don are you there sir
i am what's going on guys how are you
howdy we're doing welsh oh look you got
the beer now are you glad that you get
to keep the beard uh since you're not
you know technically did you have to
shave when you were kind of there you
know in
not in office but part of you know what
i mean
now i think i've had the beard pretty
much since my father went into office i
think when he wasn't in our corporate
offices every day it sort of gave me a
little bit he's a little bit old school
that way you know coat and tie and clean
shaven and not really my style but uh
you know once he went down to washington
dc i was in new york i just sort of went
uh free reign yeah well you know you're
kind of going more the bass pro uh style
or cabela's yes these are my bill
yes you're like a male lesbian
um
let me ask you okay so before we get i
mean we can talk about whatever you want
to discuss here uh don but i'm sure you
probably have some opinions the the the
leak the supreme court here if you have
to wager
i think it's a liberal you think it's a
conservative source that leaked it
well i'm watching the liberals say it's
definitely a conservative i'm not sure
what it does for them right now to do
this uh you know with the disaster that
is the joe biden slash democrat you know
policy uh that's affecting our country
right now you know they have to do
something i guess to to get their base
uh
to turn out and i guess killing babies
is is that thing i mean they have
nothing else to campaign on uh clearly
not the economy you know there's a
there's a shortage of baby formula uh in
the u.s you can't get baby formula but
at least you can really you know kill
your baby really fast in this country i
mean it's it's truly sick what's
happening right now or just incidentally
because you don't have baby formula yeah
exactly so they really do either way
they find a way yeah it's great life
finds a way yes and by life i mean
corrupt democrats yes yeah i found out
yesterday about the baby formula
shortage and um
it's a problem because i don't have
breasts
but you you too can be a chest feeder uh
stephen and i i'm sure i'm sure they've
come up with a way to you know
do that you can add that formula to your
your chest feeding apparatus uh and make
it happen so that's problematic and you
know frankly i think it's rather
transphobic uh of the democrats to allow
these kind of policies to happen well
that's the problem we get back to the
chess feeder only i don't have i don't
have the formula you know it's funny
that you you mentioned this i wanted to
talk with you about this because your
dad your dad and really the whole the
whole administration made record gains
with black americans and we're actually
seeing that the good thing is we're
seeing it continue in a lot of ways if
you look at a lot of the voting so
yesterday and this will air tomorrow i
just started this new
segment it's just talking to people
which i think it's just called talking
to people i go on the street and just
talk with people about issues we talked
about roe v wade
and my conversations with black people
were very now they were democrat they
initially considered themselves
pro-choice
and by the end of the conversation
they're saying okay i understand it uh i
understand where you're lining up and
it's funny because you mentioned this
where i i asked a a black person here it
was well i was in downtown dallas we
drove uh all the way out there and i
said what do you have you heard that men
can get pregnant too and her reaction
was just she went she did this she went
i heard that [ __ ]
and it seems to me that the reason you
see these games like with latinos and
with blacks is because they're the
moderate wing of the democratic party
today
have you seen that shift
uh uh uh a hundred percent i mean you
know the insanity that is being pushed
by the left and again you know i i do
believe there are moderate democrats out
there i just don't think there's anyone
actually representing them in government
right uh you know you can't get elected
without the lunatic money from
california and new york and all these
places and so you know it's no longer
you know your grandfather's democrat
party joe biden says the same thing
about the republican party and thank god
uh you know i think we've transformed
you know nancy pelosi she really wishes
it was the republican party of uh
yesteryear you mean like the one that
just like rolls over and gives you the
win every time and you know like of
course she wants that yeah uh of course
she wants that and so i think you know
that's why you know i think my father's
presidency and his involvement in this
was so important because it showed other
conservatives like you know you don't
just have to
like roll over right you don't just have
to die like no one really cares if cnn
writes a nice article about you they
hate your guts anyway you might as well
just own that and uh and use it to your
advantage and uh you know i think that's
so fundamentally important to everything
that we're doing for you know for
conservatism to even uh be around for a
few more generations because at the rate
it was going it wouldn't have been uh
because you know we made uh
we made a living out of just losing uh
and giving up and being like well we
took the principled approach while they
laughed their asses off to the bank each
and every time and so it hasn't worked
but uh
you know i'm seeing the democrats do
sort of the opposite on that end and you
know they're pushing away their
traditional base and it's because that
traditional base is actually
understanding what today's democrat
party is actually all about and it's
insane let me ask you this what do you
think is the most pivotal issue here you
know going into midterms and then into
2024 having experience with this and a
lot of issues are up in the air right
they try and bring in covet and they try
and bring in ukraine and then roe v wade
but we just looked at the generic
republican ballot versus democrats on on
economic issues
what do you think should be the focus or
honestly not just the focus politically
what do you think is the most important
issue facing our country
listen it's got to be the economy
stephen like not nothing else matters
without that right you get you know
eight point five percent inflation now
we all know the numbers actually much
higher than that right they they're
talking about adjusting the numbers and
they're going to look at it a little bit
differently because it's double digits
it's probably pushing 25 but we can't
actually say that because then no one
will actually vote for the democrats so
you know it's always the economy like
all the blessings that we have all the
you know it comes from having a robust
economy all the craziness that even the
democrats want to do like you know i
guess when you can't feed yourself uh
you know it's a little harder to argue
about the you know innate uh details of
the trans agenda like it's
it's a little bit you know it's all
based on that there's other things that
are important you know you don't have
baby formula but you know congress is
voting today on spending you know 40
billion dollars to help ukraine so that
we can be in a proxy war with russia i
mean you know what could possibly go
wrong uh there's no logical reason to
some of these decisions anymore right
you you talk about you know joe biden
he's gonna tackle inflation he's doing a
wonderful job tackling inflation he's
like let's just send let's print some
more money and then we'll send it to a
corrupt country like the ukraine now i
understand that you know bono and you
two are performing there so that makes
everything fine and makes it worse
they're totally not a corrupt nation
right it it's ridiculous
like you know the notion of like they're
not even pretending to put like american
citizens first even their own base even
the radical wing i mean they're doing
anything but and you know i think it all
stems from the economy but you know i
think we are winning on some of these
issues when you look into the sort of
again the sheer insanity of some of what
they're pushing you know the the men can
have babies too and you know keep
running with that folks it's going to go
awesome uh
you know to the community no i want them
to do it like please please be all in on
this issue
to the communities that you were talking
about and talking too it's you know when
they hear that stuff they realize
uh that even with the trillion dollars
spent you know by the mainstream media
as their marketing arm of the democrat
party uh even with the trillion dollars
in sort of uh you know free donations
from big tech and social suppressing
conservative voices uh boosting
artificially the radical left you know
covering up their nonsense like even
with multi-trillion dollar industries
helping them out when they push what's
actually a big part of their stuff
whether it's critical race theory
whether it's you know the agenda we're
just talking about all of these things
when people see it they're like oh my
god yes uh rational reasonable people
are they are not with uh this nonsense
that's that's a man with udders yeah
what is this yeah why is this what are
you gonna ask like why do you think so
few people have seen it because when
your dad was in office i mean i i
imagine that there's a point where you
would first go well this is very
gratifying to see how horribly this went
but it's got to be at the point where
now it's just got to be
disgusting to you to see how bad of a
job biden is doing
like it's all you have to do is nothing
you know all he had to do was nothing
just like stop like you know right you
know rather than like
you know he could have been fine he
could have weathered the storm like he
doesn't have to be able to know where he
is you know it's you know it doesn't
matter he's good at that he could have
been fine but like
how about this like we'll shut down
american energy but like let's let's
negotiate with iran
and venezuela to get our energy needs
because we need to get it from somewhere
but we won't negotiate with the people
of texas or oklahoma or pennsylvania or
ohio where they actually produce this
stuff arguing well they have abortion
laws we'll deal with the world's leading
state sponsor of terror like what could
go wrong folks
um i have two questions for you because
you just mentioned the whole thing look
you and your dad your family generally
speaking you were you know more you were
conservative and somewhat socially
liberal let me sing that to a degree but
now you also just mentioned the wokeness
have you run have you run out of uh rope
there where you're like i'm kind of
socially liberal but now when we have
you know a man with fake with fake tits
breastfeeding you're like this is this
is not uh this is not uh the gay
marriage thing in california this this
is this is weird
well listen i don't i don't know that i
was ever socially liberal that's not me
but
i get where you're going with it but uh
yes i think there was a time you know
growing up in new york city where you
know and working there and being in my
20s there and you know spending that
time there that i could have those
conversations with my democrat friends
and perhaps even argue their standpoint
better than they could and hey now if
you're going to argue that point like at
least maybe try it this way or
articulate it this way and then oh yeah
like i can't even have a conversation
with these people anymore like they
don't even they can't even articulate
their points because once they get going
they like stop to think for a second
then they're like
yeah that's lunacy like it like it it
doesn't make sense right the science
isn't actually science we we know that
science is about backing up a narrative
that no longer makes sense and so we
pretended science uh you know math is
racist uh yes
it doesn't work anymore and so like i
understand a time where i could actually
communicate with people that had exactly
the opposite political sp you know
viewpoint that i always had growing up
and like you could have a conversation
and you could argue it out but like the
the spread you know the bid ask is just
so far
these days and when i look at you know
the mainstream parts of the democrat
platform like
none of it has to do with issues that
actually affect people on a day-to-day
basis you know they're catering to you
know the most extreme you know
0.001 percent of the party and that's
the mafia that has control over
everything that is today's democrat
point
and that's that's scary it's the
suburban
white female mafia that's what it is
with the democrat party right now it is
this is i think they're i think they're
losing those people now too yeah
there was a component where was like you
were cool you know when you're talking
and you're in your lululemon pants
picking up your kid at school and you
could be like you know
you're woke so it was cool but like now
you look at what it means and like these
these people i mean they're
they're literally voting against the
interest and the future of their own
children at this point you know where
are the soccer moms uh that go there and
sit there for hours watching you know
kids chase a ball
that try to get into college now when
like dudes are going to be taking their
kids scholarship like where are those
feminists yeah because you think they'd
have something to say about it i know
they would have 30 years ago but even
they're afraid to come out so i think
there's a there's a whole component of
this party
no one's willing to actually step up
finally conservatives are willing to
step up and speak up and talk about the
stupidity of the things that they've
done wrong for decades yeah no one's
there on the left yet because they're so
afraid uh that if they take on someone
who's perceived to be marginalized in
any way shape or form no matter how
radical the idea no matter how costly it
is uh no matter how much uh
total lacking of sense uh the idea may
be they're worried about that mob
mentality and you've seen them start
eating their own on this thing and so
you know i'm just going to sit back and
laugh and just point out the insanity of
it all fact check just so you know i
found this out only very recently so i
feel the need lululemon sells men's
clothes too
don't i know it
you don't look like a lululemon guy but
i found out someone's like you haven't
tried lululemon i said no no i have not
and i don't like that i know this now
that they sell men's clothes here's my
fi and then we'll go to mug club and
then i'll have some other questions for
you they're more personal but here let
me ask you this twitter first off how
many followers did you gain uh in that
unthrottling i would imagine it was huge
oh it was uh day one it was i like i
actually because i did a post about it
and i stopped posting because it it was
like 87 000 on day one hundred and
twenty thousand day two a hundred and
thirty something thousand day three like
it was it was like
it was you know close to a million
people in a week like something yeah
because yours is way bigger than half a
million people yeah mine was a quarter
million people and uh and it happens no
proof you've been science no proof
whatsoever and of course we have the
exact same thing that we you know with
youtube so we know that that's happened
where we would be gaining then we were
demonetized saw it go down remonetize go
up so we've seen it we can actually
track it to the letter but i was going
to ask you this um
what uh where are you guys because you
know you obviously work with truth
social but i heard you know obviously
your dad's statements that hey elon's
good guys is this sort of like like
friendly competition are you happy about
it
yeah listen hey listen i actually
believe this stuff steven like i i've
been out there sort of i promise you
like if there's one thing it would have
been much easier for me to do would be
to shut the [ __ ] up and just be a
business guy from new york city right
like it i promise you there's no real
upside to me being out there being sort
of an outspoken uh conservative uh you
know fighting these battles i just had
to do it because i actually believe in
this [ __ ] like i you know i have five
young kids i want growing up in a
country that like i recognize yeah uh
you know and that's not the path of the
other side right now so you know again
uh you know
with the stuff that shows me doing well
with conservatives it's like well
because maybe there's so few of us that
actually have the balls to step up and
say these things i'm hoping that that
changes i we i hope we have a a much
deeper you know bench uh and i i can
assure you that we'd actually see a real
change if it's not just like donald
trump donald trump and stephen crowder
donald trump and donald trump jr with
steven crowder you know three guys five
guys ten guys going out there you know
it's easy to channel all the fire on
those people to cancel them and all that
stuff i mean we are up against you know
that we're not in a fair fight yeah if
you get you know all 150 million you
know conservative let's take half the
country and divide it and there's
probably many more independence with
what the left is doing you know coming
over if those people become unafraid
like there's no question elections based
on what we are up against should be like
99.9 to 0.01
uh you know when you think about like
what we're up against when you talk
about the entire force of mainstream
media the entire force of big tech and
everything that's out there the entire
force of social so you know i actually
believe in this stuff so like i'm
thrilled for anything that adds to
actual free speech notice you know the
notion of free speech
uh used to be a pretty common thing and
when the left controlled twitter for
decades they love their idea of free
speech which meant free speech for them
but not really for anyone else right
watching them lose their minds that the
notion that they may be competing
on a level playing field is truly
remarkable i'm watching these guys like
imagine this like someone could maybe
turn up the volume on one side and turn
to i'm like
like welcome to my world for the last
seven eight years like what are you
talking about they they don't even know
that it's going on because they're just
really happy having sort of an
artificial wind presented to them every
step of the way the second like you
actually challenge that they lose their
minds yeah it's it's special to watch so
i'm you know i'm happy for anything that
does it i hope you know i hope people
can do the same thing with facebook and
with other platforms that you know
google would be really nice that ain't
going to happen anytime soon that's
always going to be ridiculously biased
you know that uh youtube same thing you
know but there are guys doing it you
know
so i'm spending you know a lot of time
on truth social my engagement on truth
social is with a fraction of the
followers is significantly higher right
uh than it is on twitter uh even even
now um that's like when we go we do our
live shows me and dave will you know do
a venue and it'll be like a couple
thousand people uh and a huge portion of
them are there with mugs their mug club
where we still get a good amount of
viewers but not nearly what we get
across all the platforms like youtube
and rumble but they're really really uh
engaged audience and a very supportive
audience and very good people and so
there's value to both right casting a
wide net and then having the people who
also you know it's almost to pay it
forward those are the people who take
your message and move it forward my
final question before we go to mug club
when you're because i have twins now so
you know when i'm trying to teach them
how to speak they're really young when
your dad taught you how to speak did he
teach you doing this
like because everyone in the family does
this
yeah
i i think it's just one of those yeah
it's a it's a recessive trait i can't
shake it it's just in the gym it's like
say dad dad you're like dada no
all right look we're gonna go to bug
club we're that way no one uh we don't
have to worry about getting in trouble
at all we're gonna be with donald trump
jr for uh just another uh few minutes
here youtube well you have every reason
to piss off
you